موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت الاذاعه
الاسرائيليه ان الخارجيه الامريكيه استدعت
سفير اسرائيل في واشنطن مايكرزو وهو بخت
بعد اقرار الكنيست قانونا يلغي اخلاء اربع
مستوطنات في شمال الضفه الغربيه واضافت
الاذاعه ان نائبه وزير الخارجيه وانتشار
من اعربت عن قلق واشنطن
الذي وصفته بالاستفزازي واوضحت المسؤوله
الامريكيه ان ميشان الخطوه ان تدفع الى
مزيد من التوتر خلال شهر رمضان واعياد
الفصح اليهودي والمسيحي
اقر الكنيسه الاسرائيلي بالقراءتين
الثانيه والثالثه ما يعرف بقانون ظروف عدم
اهليه رئيس الحكومه وذلك في جلسه امتدت
حتى ساعات فجر اليوم وسرع الائتلاف
اليميني الديني المتطرف تمرير القانون
وذلك لنزع انفاذه من صلاحيات المحكمه
العليا والمستشار القضائي للحكومه حيث ينص
القانون الجديد على ان عدم اهليه رئيس
الحكومه تكون باعلانه شخصيا عن عدم قدرته
القيام بواجباته لدواعي صحيه او نفسيه او
من خلال توصيه من 75% من اعضاء الكنيست
اعتبرت المعارضه ان القانون يهدف لحمايه
نتنياهو الذي يحاكم بثلاثه ملفات فساد
ومتهم بعدم السيطره على حكومته من اصدار
المحكمه العليا والمستشار القضائي قرارا
بعزله بعدم اهليته
افاد موقع ريبارا العسكري الروسي ان
الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت ثلاث مسيرات
اوكرانيا كانت في طريقها لاستهداف خليج
سيفا ستوبل في شبه جزيره القرم وقال
الموقع ان المسيرات الثلاث اسقطت فوق
البحر دون ان تبلغ اهدافها دون ان تبلغ
اهدافها وكانت سلطات شبه الجزيره قد اعلنت
تفعيل انظمه الدفاع الجوي مساء الاثنين في
مدينه جانكوي بعد اصابه شخص اثر سقوط حطام
طائره مسيره على احد منازلها
قال الرئيس الجزائري عبد المجيد تبون في
مقابله مع الجزيره ان العلاقه بين الجزائر
والمغرب وصلت الى نقطه لا عوده وانه ياسف
للوصول علاقه البلدين الجارين الى هذا
المستوى مشيرا الى ان موقف بلاده كان رد
فعل كما اعتبر موقف اسبانيا من الصحراء
موقفا فرديا منحازا من حكومه سانشيز وصف
العلاقه مع فرنسا بالمتذبذبه لافتا الى ان
السفير الجزائري قد يعود قريبا الى باريس
وعن الحرب في اوكرانيا قال ان الجزائر
مؤهله للاعب دوري الوسيط كونها من الدول
التي تملك مصداقيه كافيه للوساطه واضاف ان
تونس تتعرض لمؤامره والجزائر تقف معها احب
تقف مع من احب احب من احب وكره من كره
اشخاص على الاقل واصيب 47 في اقليم خيبر
في باكستان بعد ان ضرب المنطقه زلزال بقوه
6 درجات ونصف الدرجه في ساعه متاخره من
مساء الثلاثاء وقالت السلطات انما لا يقل
عن 19 منزلا تضررت بمنطقه بختون خيبر
واظهرت مقاطع فيديو بثها ناشطون اللحظات
الاولى لوقوع الزلزال
الى اللقاء